Bini: Hello.
Welcome everybody.
Oh, wow, this is echo.
Um, okay, so this is
the last talk of the day.
So I'm very happy that
so many of you showed up.
This is also pretty much
of a niche, uh, talk.
And it's also
slightly schizophrenic
because, basically, I've been
doing several different things
on App Engine, and this talk
is gonna be what--
about what I've done,
basically.
The main focus
is gonna be JRuby,
but I'm also gonna talk a little
bit about something called Ioke.
And that's about it
for introductions.
Well, actually, I'm gonna keep
this a little bit short,
so we have lots of time
for questions afterwards.
And I'm also informed that this
is the last talk of the day,
so the shorter this talk is,
the sooner people can get
to their beers.
I work for a company
called ThoughtWorks,
as a consultant, programming
language geek, whatever.
I spend
lots of time with JRuby.
I'm one of the core developers
for JRuby,
and I'm gonna be talking more
about what JRuby is soon.
I'm Swedish, so if I pronounce
something very weirdly,
that's because I'm not
a native English speaker,
so, um, just so you know.
Anyway, um, I've written
a book about JRuby
a few years back,
and I've been
spending lots of time
in Java and Ruby communities,
especially the last few years.
And that's about it.
ThoughtWorks is
a global consulting firm.
We have offices
all over the place,
including
here in San Francisco...
about 1,100 people.
We have invested quite a lot
of time and money in Ruby,
and we actually did
a lot of Ruby work in 2007.
We're the largest Ruby company
in the world, actually,
so that explains a little bit
our interest in Ruby
and other kinds of technologies
like that.
We also are famous for Agile.
We spend lots of time
on Open Source.
Chances are if you have used
any Open Source tool,
you've probably used code
that someone from ThoughtWorks
has contributed.
Martin Fowler is
our chief scientist,
and that's actually
the main reason we're famous
in many circles.
We have
something called Studios,
which is a product division,
and these products
are all really cool.
They solve problems
for most development teams,
so I urge you
to check them out.
Okay, so how many
in this audience know Ruby?
Oh, wow.
That's perfect.
That's almost everyone, so
I'm sorry for the rest of you.
If you don't know Ruby,
try to--
[chuckles]
try to follow along anyway.
I'm not gonna--I have--
I think I have--
If you wanna know what Ruby is,
read this slide really quickly.
Or, rather--well,
it's pretty interesting.
The one thing that
I find interesting
about Ruby as a language is that
it's actually older than Java,
but it sprung out on the scene
of common knowledge
the last few years,
thanks to Rails
and other things like that.
There are some features of Ruby
that you should know about,
if you--if you
don't know Ruby.
These are the main ones
in my mind,
compared to Java for example.
And...let's see.
These are--these are basically
some of the main things
that I'm
gonna be talking about.
Just so you don't
get totally lost,
RubyGems is
the package management tool.
Rake is the build tool,
and you can also use Rake
for doing lots of other things.
RSpec is one of the standard
testing tools.
Rails and Merb--
web application frameworks.
Ramaze and Sinatra--
also web application frameworks.
And that's it
about pure Ruby.
How many here
have played with JRuby?
Okay, so that's
about 30%, 40%.
So I'm gonna spend some
more time introducing JRuby.
Basically, JRuby is
an implementation of Ruby.
It's as compatible as we can
make it on top of Java.
It runs on Java 1.5.
and upwards.
It's an
Open Source project,
and it's compatible with
Ruby 1.8.6, specifically.
We're adding Ruby 1.9 features.
They're not complete yet.
But we're trying to add them
as good as possible.
The current version of JRuby
is 1.2,
and we actually
just yesterday released
our second release candidate
of 1.3.
And 1.3 is gonna be
the JRuby version
you should be using
if you want to use JRuby
on Google App Engine,
for example.
We are gonna release
the final version of 1.3
next week at Java 1.
So one thing I want to spend
some time on is why JRuby,
especially since
almost everyone in the audience
actually knows Ruby.
This question is a little bit
more pertinent.
What's wrong with
the regular Ruby interpreter?
And I'm not gonna say
everything is wrong
with the regular
Ruby interpreter,
but there are many things
that could have been better,
and things that actually
cause lots of problems
for people, uh,
trying to do things on MRI.
The first one
is threading.
So MRI is
green-threaded,
which means that
all threads
belong to one, um,
operating system process,
which means that you can't
really use any cores
if you have that
in your system.
You have to spawn new threads,
uh, new processes
to actually use
new cores.
In JRuby, we solve this
by using Java threads.
So a Ruby thread
is a Java thread,
and that's basically it.
So threads are
a little bit cheaper on MRI,
but threads actually
can help you scale on JRuby.
That's kind of
the trade-off.
Ruby has traditionally been
very patchy
in its support for Unicode,
and if you want to use Unicode,
and do some kind of
multilingualization,
or--or anything that
works outside of the U.S.,
you're gonna have to use some
pretty hairy techniques
in many cases.
And they don't work
all over the place,
so the implementation
has been patchy at best.
In JRuby, we--
to be compatible with Ruby,
we had to actually mimic
all those bad things.
But we also give you
access to Java strings,
so you can actually use Unicode
the way Java allows
you to do that, um, from JRuby
by using Java strings instead.
Ruby and 2C/S generally say
that Ruby is fast enough,
and fast enough,
in that definition, is still
enough to put you
at the slowest place
in the
comparisons between
different dynamic
programming languages.
JRuby is between
two and ten times faster,
depending on
how you measure.
In average, you're seeing
between four and five times
the same, um,
compared to MRI.
Compared to 1.9 we are,
in most benchmarks,
a little bit faster,
in some benchmarks slower,
and in some benchmarks
very much faster.
So we are actually setting
our goals against 1.9 right now.
The reasons we are faster--there
are several reasons for this.
The first one is that JRuby
has both an interpreter
and a byte code
compiler.
And we actually switched
from interpretive mode
to compiled mode
per method,
so if you have a method
that really gets called a lot
we compile that down
to Java byte code.
And then Java takes the--
Java HotSpot basically
takes those byte codes
and profiles them
and turns them into
very efficient Native code
where it's needed.
So we get pretty good
performance, actually.
Any medium to large
Ruby application
will leak memory
because
the MRI Garbage Collector
is a very naive implementation,
and it leaks memory.
That's basically fact.
JRuby uses all the
Garbage Collectors in the Java--
on the Java implementation.
So that means that, basically,
we just get the same kind
of performance as Java
applications get from the--
uh, and the same kind of
memory benefits.
You can also use the same way
you tune a Java application
to tune your, uh,
Ruby Garbage Collection.
There are four algorithms
in Java right now,
and there's gonna be
a new one in Java 7
that makes Garbage Collection
really, really
even better than
it is right now.
If you can see
the trend here,
the trend is basically that
we use the Java ecosystem.
We use the JVM.
We don't really do
anything extra in JRuby
to support these features.
They're just there because
we're on the top of the JVM.
C Extensions are really annoying
to write for Ruby.
So in JRuby, you basically
write a Java extension instead.
A Java extension avoids
many of the problems
that you had when you wrote
the C extension for Ruby.
A few of the examples
of things that can go wrong
when you write C extensions is
that, first of all,
you can bring down
the whole interpreter.
Secondly, there's no
well-defined API
for how you work with
the MRI interpreter from C.
So the C extensions can do,
basically, whatever they want.
That's really powerful, but it's
also very, uh, very harmful
because the interpreter
can't really be safe,
that anything in its internal
systems is gonna be unchanged.
So with JRuby we basically just
allow you to use Java classes.
And since we
implemented JRuby
in the [indistinct]
or in the system,
we get encapsulation
and interfaces for free,
and additionally,
in JRuby,
you generally don't need
to write Java extensions.
It's basically
one case in ten
of the cases where you write
C extensions
where you in JRuby need
to write a Java extension,
because in most cases you could
just use Java code
directly from Ruby.
So JRuby allows you access
to any Java Library out there.
We can use anything,
and it's very nicely integrated.
So you just use it.
It works.
I'm gonna
skip over those.
So it's very easy
to get started with JRuby.
You have to have Java
installed.
I guess that's pretty common
in this audience.
You download the tarball,
and then you get JRuby.
You get the Ruby
standard library.
You get the RubyGems,
and you get Rake.
And then
you unpack it.
You can have multiple copies
anywhere you want.
And the only thing
you need to do
if you want to be using
your JRuby from anywhere
is to have the bin directory
on the PATH.
Then you can start
installing gems, for example.
If you only have JRuby
on your system,
you can do
gem install RSpec,
but if you have several
different Ruby implementations,
you should use
JRuby-S
to specify that you want
the gem version for JRuby
and nothing else.
You can also call out to Ruby
from Java, if you want to.
This is with the Java 6
Script Engine Manager,
and it's basically
very, very simple code.
You get the engine by name,
and then you evaluate it,
and that's about it.
It's not that hard,
actually.
There are also support in
the bin scripting foundation
to do these things,
and you can call out to
the JRuby engine directly
if you want to.
Depending on your needs,
these three versions
solve different problems.
So JRuby, as I mentioned,
allows you access
to any Java libraries.
We call that feature
Java Integration.
Basically, Java types
look like they are Ruby types.
You can do--anything you can
do in a Ruby type,
you can do
on the Java type.
So you can call methods,
you can construct instances,
you can pass those
objects around, et cetera.
We also--since Ruby uses
snake_case in this library,
we, uh,
and Java uses camelCase,
um, so we try to switch.
So when you code against
the Java library,
you can use
either snake_case or camelCase.
The transformation
is canonical,
and we won't do it if there are
existing methods with that name.
But this actually makes
your Java code,
or the code using Java,
look much more like Ruby,
which is sometimes
a good thing.
JRuby can implement interfaces
and also inherit from classes.
We have something
called closure conversion.
In many of those cases
where you have
an anonymous
class implementation in Java,
you basically just want to have
that implementation,
send it
in to something.
In that case,
it's just boiler plate
to have to write the name
of the class or interface,
the name of the method,
and all that stuff around it.
So with JRuby,
if you send in a block
to one of those methods
that takes something like this,
it will basically just
turn the block
into an implementation
of that interface
or an extension
of the classing question.
This makes some code
very, very terse
compared, to--
to the general case.
I'm gonna show how these--
what these features look like.
We also have added
some extra features
to Java classes
and interfaces
to make them
much easier to work with.
We can add any kind of--
since Ruby has open classes,
we can add anything
to Ruby classes.
That means also that we can
add any new method we want
to a Java class too.
So I'm gonna show you
a little bit
what our Java Integration
looks like.
And I'm gonna be using--
let's see.
Here we are.
Uh, "jirb,"
which is the interactive
Ruby prompt for JRuby.
And it's basically the same
as the interactive prompt
for regular Ruby.
Can everyone see this?
Is there someone
who can't see it?
Okay, uh,
no answer at all.
I can do 1 plus 1, et cetera.
I can also
use the Java class...
and say, "Hello World,"
in a slightly more verbose way.
I can import classes,
but importing a class
doesn't really do exactly
what it does in Java.
In Ruby, import basically
does exactly the same thing
as doing
HashMap=java.util.HashMap.
So it just sets the name
in the local scope.
I can use, oops.
I can use the HashMaps.
So I can create a new Hash
by doing--
calling that new,
and I can add stuff to it.
This, uh,
as you can see,
we have added index,
or the--the square brackets
so you can work
with these, um--
with the Hash
like it was a Ruby Hash,
while it actually is
a Java Hash in this case.
As you can see,
if we'd printed,
you can see that it says
that it's a Java,
JavaUtil HashMap,
And--and the name
on the left-hand side,
that's the canonical way
we refer to Java classes.
In most, whoa--
in most cases, it is easier
to refer to them
in other ways,
but if you really want
to understand what we're doing
with the
Java integration features,
that's the--the way
you get access to it.
We can see that this is still
a Java object,
and if we call
to_s to it,
we can see that we get a HashMap
way of printing this stuff.
So we can work with this,
just like it was any Ruby class.
And we have added
lots of other stuff.
So, for example,
JavaUtil list.
It's innumerable.
So you can use all innumerable
methods on Java lists
and so on.
You can also get access
to other APIs.
So Java Security,
for example,
has this funny method called
get_algorithms.
Now, I did something interesting
a few years back,
when I was--
I was working on creating
a Java-based implementation
of OpenSSL
using the Java security APIs
instead of the primitives
on OpenSSL.
And I needed this
get_algorithms method
all the time.
And the problem with it is
that get_algorithms doesn't
really describe,
how, what,
the result looks like,
so I have to basically create
lots of, whoops--
lots of small test classes
to see what I get back
from calling this
in different ways.
So instead of creating
those small classes,
I instead open up
Java and JRuby's IRB,
and I call the method
from it here,
and I can just see that,
in this case,
I get algorithms
that look like this.
And I can modify them
and work with them
like I could with any
in the Ruby class.
I can sort them, I can grep
for a specific algorithm,
and so on.
This is mostly useful
for Java APIs that have
bad documentation
or documentation that doesn't
tell you anything.
Like, for example,
if you wanna check
for corner cases in their
regular expression APIs
for Java,
this is the perfect place
of handling it.
I used to have
a Spikes directory,
where I had, like,
a hundred Java classes
that were just five lines long
to do stuff.
I don't do that anymore because
I have--I can--I can
test all those things in the
interactive prompt and stuff.
Now, those examples were
a little bit useful.
So I'm gonna finish by showing
a slightly more useless example.
But it's very flashy, or
a little bit flashy, at least.
Since I can work with
any Java APIs,
that means that I can,
for example,
work with Swing.
Let's see.
Create a new frame here.
This is gonna
take some time,
because I'm running
[indistinct],
so it needs to start X11 in
the background the first time.
Sorry about that.
And there we get X11,
and now we can
set the size
and we can show it.
And here I have a Swing frame
that I've created dynamically.
Now, everything
is not over.
I can actually
work with the Swing frames.
I can create a new JButton,
for example,
that says,
"Hello World."
And then I add that
to the frame,
and then I show
the frame again,
and you can see
we have this beautiful button
that covers the whole thing.
It doesn't really
do anything,
but that's okay,
because we can add behavior
after the fact.
This is not static, right?
So we can add
an action_listener.
And my problem here
is that I never remember
what the interface
is called.
And--and I don't really
believe in IDs
that remember stuff
for me.
Because
if it remembers for me,
it can write
the stuff for me,
and that means that I will be
writing lots of code
that I haven't
actually been typing,
which means that I will
have to read that code later on,
and that's the stuff
that I really dislike.
So since I don't
remember the interface,
or actually,
I think I do remember it,
but anyway, the code for
implementing this interface
would be a little bit
annoying.
And I don't really care.
The only thing I want to do
is do something
when someone
pushes this button.
So in this case,
I'm just gonna say,
"Give it a block."
And I say,
"button pressed."
And, "end."
And then I go here.
And we can see that
we're triggering Ruby code
from a
Java Swing interface here.
Um, I can also add
a new action_listener
that can do
some stuff here.
"E" is the Event,
and Event has this, um,
method called Source.
Actually, the method name
is Get Source.
But since this is Ruby,
and the Ruby convention
is not to use Get
in the names,
uh, JRuby actually
adds aliases.
So just doing that source
will get--
will evoke
the method called Get Source.
The same thing
is done with text
with setters.
So there is no method
called text =
on the--on the button.
Instead, there's a method
called setText.
But this does exactly
the same thing.
So I can modify this interface
and I can go back here.
And when I press it now,
the text changes.
So that's
a very, very small example
of how you can work
with Ruby code and Java code,
and just mix and match,
and do whatever you--you--
in different pieces,
exactly what you want to do.
The key thing to remember
is that you can do--
anything you can do from Java,
you can really do from Ruby
as long as it makes sense
so to speak.
There are a--
[laughs]
There are
a few caveats to that.
The thing is, some of the things
that you you want to do--
uh, that you want to do
in Java
doesn't really make sense
to do in Ruby.
A typical example
is annotations.
Now, annotations
are really useful,
but they're
a static feature.
And since Ruby is running,
JRuby is running at runtime.
Uh, it's already too late
to add those static features
when the Ruby program
is running.
So annotations
doesn't actually make sense
for a Ruby program,
or at least Java annotation
doesn't make sense
for a Ruby program.
Another typical thing
is generics.
Ruby doesn't have
generics,
and the JVM doesn't have
generics either.
It's just the Java language
that has generics.
So there is no syntax
for working with generics
because it doesn't really
make sense to, uh,
to work with the APIs
at runtime with generics
since they don't exist
at runtime in Java.
Okay, so let's switch over
to Rails a little bit.
I assume that everyone here
who knew Ruby
actually knows Rails too,
so I'm gonna just, uh,
skip over this...really.
But this one is
a little bit more interesting.
So Rails works perfectly
on the JRuby.
It's very easy
to get started and set up.
It's basically the same thing as
starting out a Rails application
with regular Ruby.
The only thing
you need to do differently
is to use a different
ActiveRecord driver
for the database because you
can't really use ActiveRecord.
Instead, you need to use
something called
ActiveRecord JRubyC
that allows you to use JRubyC
to back
your Rails application.
We have
very good performance
and lots of deployments
of JRuby.
And you get access
to all the libraries in Java.
You can create
a Rails application
they use in CJBs and so on,
if you really feel perverse.
It's very easy
to deploy.
The Rails deployment story
has for a long time been
a little bit, uh,
annoying.
This is getting better,
but in the JRuby world,
it's very, very easy
to deploy.
Basically you just package
your Rails application
into a WAR file.
And then you deploy
that WAR file
exactly like you would
any Java web application.
JRubyC allows much better
database support
than, uh, than Rails does
in general,
and it's also
totally platform independent.
So you can run--
this is one of the examples
that we have.
I find this
pretty nice, actually.
I'm sure you couldn't do that
with regular Ruby.
Okay, I said earlier that
JRuby is compatible with Ruby.
Uh, that was a lie.
Or, a truth
with modification.
Basically, there are a few
things that doesn't really work,
or that we have changed.
The obvious one is that
you can use Java classes.
But that is no real change
in lib--in syntax.
The only change there
is in libraries.
And you could--
if you really want to,
you can, you can use, uh,
the Ruby-Java Bridge,
and implement the same API,
for example.
But JRuby is still
the most compatible
alternative implementation,
and it's the only one that runs
basically all Ruby applications.
Native threads
versus green threads
generally doesn't
make a difference
except for in a few
special cases.
Many Ruby libraries
depend on unsafe things,
and the reason they do that
is because
it's safe to do them
when you have green threads
because they have
the deterministic scheduler.
We can never guarantee
that kind of thing
with native threads.
So some of the libraries--
for example, Timeout
is a library that is
a little bit evil to use at all.
C extensions
are not supported right now.
We're working on that,
and we should have support
for it in a while.
It's a little bit tricky
to provide support
for C extensions
from JRuby
because--not because
it's hard to call out to C,
but the thing is
about the C extensions
is that they--
as I mentioned earlier,
since the Ruby MRI interpreter
doesn't really have
any good interface
to its internals,
these C extensions,
they do all kinds
of really nasty things,
which means that for us
to be able to support them,
we need to fake out
those things
so that the JRuby stuff
looks like they have
the same internal structure
as the Ruby implementation.
That's not entirely trivial,
but we're working on that.
We don't support
full continuations.
No one has really
complained about that.
We don't support fork.
Well, actually
we have fork.
Fork is working.
But we have turned it off
because it's not really
a good thing to fork
your web sphere or whatever
in production.
I think that people
is gonna be a little bit mad
if some library does that.
ObjectSpace is turned off
by default.
You can turn it on
if you want to.
It's gonna cost you
about half your performance
if you do it.
And there generally
better ways of doing stuff.
Okay, so I mentioned
it's very easy
to package things.
Basically, you need something
called Warbler.
It's a self-contained thing
that includes JRuby
and a servlet adapter.
And you do
gem install warbler,
then inside of your
Rails application,
you do warble config.
And then finally,
you do warble.
And at that point
you have a WAR file.
Rack is one of those APIs
that people are using
to provide
uniform access
to different
web application APIs.
How many here
knows about Rack?
Okay, so that's about 50%.
That's pretty good too.
Basically all Ruby web
frameworks support Rack now.
And we have something
called JRuby-rack,
which is a RackServlet.
It's basically a servlet
that dispatches to Rack.
So that means
that any web framework
that supports Rack
can be used
with JRuby-rack.
And it handles pooling
and stuff like that too.
Okay, so I have spoken
for a while
without coming into
the Google App Engine stuff.
That should
hopefully change now.
So JRuby works fine
under Google App Engine.
People have tested several
different web frameworks
and so on.
It's still a little bit--
There are still
a few things
that makes this
not totally trivial.
It works more or less
as you would expect it,
but it's a few things
you need to keep in mind.
Some of these things--
So Reggae is basically
a library that tries
to take care
of some of these things.
It stands for
Ruby Enabled Google App Engine,
and it provides simple
support for configuration,
packaging
Gems into Jar files,
simplify the running
of Rack applications
on the local
development server.
The local development server
is...
I think I have a slide
for the problems,
but the local
development server
is a problem in general
because it doesn't
really mimic exactly
the Google App Engine
that you upload stuff to.
So if you run
your unit test locally
on the dev server,
that doesn't really mean
that it will run the same
on the Google
App Engine stuff.
So in principle,
you should be able to use
the local dev server.
In practice,
I stopped doing that
because it didn't
really work.
So that makes it
a little bit annoying to--
You don't really have
the quick turnaround
that you would expect
from a Rails application.
So you need to deploy it
to test basically.
Reggae tries to fix
some of these problems.
I don't know how far
they've come to that.
It's supposed to also help
with deployment,
but it's not really
done that yet.
And it could--probably needs
some really good Ruby hackers
to help out.
For interacting with
the Google App Engine APIs,
we have--for example,
we have DataMapper.
DataMapper is a Ruby ORM
that has support for lots
of different back ends.
And it actually
has an adapter for BigTable.
It's called
dm-datastore-adapter.
It doesn't support everything
DataMapper supports, of course,
because basically
DataMapper is a full ORM tool
that's supposed to support
everything you can do
to an RDBMS.
That can't--you can't do that
on Google App Engine.
So it only supports
the kind of things
that you actually can do
with BigTable.
Another one
of those libraries--
and this is a specific one.
This is just, like,
10, 20 lines of code,
but it's enough.
It's a library called BeeU
that allows you to integrate
your Rails application
with the UserService.
Basically, you get
person and admin status
automatically set.
It's very, very
easy to use.
I'm actually gonna
show this code later
because, yeah,
I have a Rails application
that I'm gonna show you.
Oh, let's see.
Okay, let's kill X11.
Sorry.
Okay, so the actual
application, first of all,
looks like this.
It's a very, very, very simple
blog post thingy.
And, um...
Let's see if I can--
if it actually responds to me.
The first request
is kind of slow sometimes.
So I can create
a new blog here.
I can go in and--and
add new posts, for example.
And look here at--at the fact
that I'm logged in here.
I can log out.
And the way this works is that
if you're logged in
but not an administrator,
uh, you can add comments.
If you are logged in,
but as an administrator
for the appspot stuff,
you're able--you're able
to post new posts
and--and remove stuff
and so on.
And this is all using the--
my Gmail account
so the integration is...
dead simple, really.
Let's see...
if this...
Okay, this takes time.
Sorry about that.
This is basically just
the, um, the, um,
single sign-on stuff.
And now I'm back
at the start again,
so I can go back to the front
and so on.
And you can see here
that I don't have
access to remove stuff,
and so on.
This code is
very, very simple.
It's more of a proof of concept
than anything else,
and it's actually--
You can download the code
from my GitHub account.
And--but I'm gonna show you
a few of the pieces
that actually, uh--the things
you need to do
to make
a Rails application run.
So first of all,
it's--it's pretty simple.
You need
App Engine XML
and you need
a datastore indexes.
to be able to...
to do joins.
This stuff is all pretty much--
pretty much documented.
This one
set some properties.
Actually, these are--
except for these two,
these two are
the only properties
that you need to do
for JRuby right now.
The rest of them are actually
the default ones, I think.
But this is just basically
exactly the same thing
as it works in the, um,
uh, for the Java stuff.
Warbler, um, you need
to specifically include
the App Engine web,
and the datastore
indexes files.
And you need to...
actually--
you can actually set this down
because you're never gonna get
more than one runtime, anyway.
And you need to make sure that
no Java libraries are included,
uh, in this way,
because you need to add all your
Java libraries yourself.
So in this case you
need to have App Engine API,
and, uh,
you need to have JRuby
and you need to have
JRuby Rack.
And those--all of them
can be found on the net
in a pretty simple--
with a--with one of those
very nice search engines
we--we probably know
all about.
Okay, so
configuration_vice--
this application
is pretty simple too.
The one thing that it does here
is that it actually requires
big_table_servlet_store.
I created my own servlet_store
to store, uh, sessions
in--in big_tables there
because I found that
the way sessions worked--
are a little bit tricky
on Google App Engine.
I'm taking and removing
active_record.
I don't need active_record
at all.
And then finally--
let's see, what do I do here?
I set the
big_table_servlet_store,
and I require something
called bumble.
Bumble is also
a very small project,
to basically give you something
that looks like active_record
but uses, uh
big_table underneath.
So let's take a look
at the actual
model files first.
These ones
all use bumble,
and this is the way
you work with them.
Ds describes the, the, the
properties you want to be using.
You need to do this to get
automatically generated
properties,
so you can work
with this.
You can still
add new stuff to this
exactly like you--exactly like
you would with big_table,
with the core APIs,
but this is how you get
some nice accessories.
You can say, belongs_to
and has_many.
This one says that
the order should be inverted:
created_at,
for example.
And see--
a person has a given_name,
a sur_name;
an email
has_many blogs.
And finally, a post has a title,
content, created_at and blog_id.
And that's basically it.
It's a very,
very simple model.
So when I go into
the BlogsController here,
you can see
this looks more or less
the same as you would do
in--in
regular active_record.
The start action
fetches all the posts
by doing Post.all
and limiting to 15 and
inverted order from created_at.
This--what gets
all the blogs.
This one gets
a specific blog by ID.
This one gets a specific post,
et cetera, et cetera.
And you see that we can
refer to the blog, et cetera,
just like you would accept,
uh, expect.
Creating new things
you can do
in the same manner as an
active_record with blog.create.
Nothing really fancy there,
actually.
All of this stuff
more or less works
like you would expect
it to do, actually.
Uh, post.delete,
post.all.each, et cetera.
Uh, BeeU--
as you saw the whole way
when I used Log In and so on--
that was actually
provided by BeeU,
and I use it
by using include BeeU here
and then I assign user
and admin status
and they will set
instance variables
with these values.
And then I also have this
assign_person filter
that will, um--
if a user exists, will try to
find that person in big_table,
and if we don't
find a matching person
for the user,
we'll create a new one based on
the information from the user.
This is actually
the user interface,
so this is actually
Java code I'm calling out here,
but you can't see it because
it looks exactly like Ruby code.
And in the blogs,
I can have security
by saying recruit--
require_admin,
and just name the actions
that need admin security.
And that's all I need to do
to make sure that these
don't show up
and so on.
Um, so this application is
really, really, really simple.
This is really
all it does.
It could do
some more stuff.
I have some, uh--
I have a test controller
where I added
some new stuff.
This is actually
commented out.
I have a rendering
of some simple stuff,
and I also have
this Ruby action
that actually will
instance_eval new stuff.
So you can test anything
in the server.
Finally, I have something
called run_tests
because I created a
small, small, small, small
test framework
called yak_test.
And yak_test allows me to, uh,
first publish the application
to the server, and then
run tests on the server instance
and then get the report back,
uh, into it.
The reason I needed that
was basically because
I needed to do
unit testing on the server.
And none of the RSpec
or test/unit for those
had support for doing
that kind of thing.
And I think that's really,
really all I'm gonna show
from this application
right now.
Yep, okay.
So that was
the Rails application running.
Um, as I mentioned,
it's just--
take a look at my GitHub account
if you want to see the code.
It's nothing complicated
at all.
There we are.
Okay, so I mentioned
that Sinatra works.
It's a very small DSL for
writing Ruby web applications.
And the simplest, simplest
thing you can do
looks like this.
Using Warbler,
you can package this up
using JRuby rack,
and you can just use it.
And it's gonna work more or less
exactly like running it locally.
Ramaze is also a very nice
web framework
that runs on Rack
and works with DataMapper.
Right now there is
this problem with threads.
As you might know,
Google App Engine
actually restricts you,
so you can't really use threads.
So any library that needs
to use threads
needs to be patched.
There are some other limits
that you need to keep in mind
when doing
a Ruby application.
The first one--
there are a few limits on files.
You can't have more than
1,000 files in your application.
Of course, this sounds like--
well, of course.
That's not gonna be
any problem, right?
Until you freeze all the Rails
gems into your application.
Since you need to freeze
these gems,
you will actually end up with,
like, 800 files
just from freezing those gems
into your--
into your vendor library.
And then you get
a few more files after that.
So that 1,000 files,
you need to use a specific--
there's a gem for packaging
gems into JAR files
that you can use.
And you also have a restriction
on how large JAR files can be.
And especially in the last
version of JRuby,
the JRuby complete JAR file
was actually larger
than ten megs,
so you need to split
that one.
Reggae is supposed to help you
with those kind of things.
We don't
really support, uh--
[laughs]
Image API.
There is something called
Image Google App Engine
that you can use
to get around
because there are Image APIs
in Google App Engine,
but they are not really
standardized
and they don't really
work with JRuby out of the box.
Well, you can use them
as Java libraries,
but there is no Ruby support
to do it.
As I mentioned,
no threads.
This is gonna be problematic
in some cases
because Ruby
actually uses threads
in some
very strange places.
As I mentioned, Timeout
uses threads by default.
Actually, JRuby
has replaced that
so we don't do that
anymore,
but there are thread users
all over the place.
So if you get strange errors
or exceptions in your logs
that complain about threads,
that's because you can't
use threads, basically.
You can't even
write to files either.
So if you have anything that
depends on being able
to write to file,
you're gonna have
some trouble with that.
One of the things that bit--
that will bite you in JRuby
is that reflection doesn't work
in everything.
So, for example,
you can't call specific methods
on object, for example.
You can't do set_accessible on
unprotected methods, and so on.
So if you--if you want
to do really weird stuff,
and, uh, you--
some of the weird stuff you
might be able to do with JRuby.
You will hit in some limitations
because of the reflection stuff.
The biggest problem of them all,
though, is the start-up time
because right now, the--
the combined start-up time
of JRuby on Rails
is actually pretty large.
It's like--
the first request
to start up a new JRuby runtime
takes almost 15 seconds.
There are ways
to get around that,
to get that down to something
like 7 or 6,
but it's still
a problem
and--and we are actually--
I've been talking
to--to several
Google engineers
and we're trying to figure out
a way of solving this.
The problem is that the way
the Google App Engine
architecture works is that,
well, basically you have
no shared state, of course,
so you can't share engines.
So every concurrent request is--
is gonna need its own--
its own
JRuby runtime.
I don't really have a solution
to how to solve that right now.
One of the ways you can
get around it right now
is to use something
that is not Rails.
If you use Ramaze or Sinatra,
they're gonna be much smaller,
so they're gonna load
much faster.
Testing is really problematic,
as I mentioned.
Local testing--I have had
no success at all
with local testing,
actually.
You can do unit tests
of your implementations
if you--if you disregard
all the, um,
uh, all the
Google App Engine stuff.
But, uh, basically you
need to run the functional tests
on, uh,
on Google App Engine
to be sure.
So one of the ways
you can do that
in building in testing triggers
into your application,
like I showed you
with the yak_test stuff--
you can do that,
or you can use
something like Selenium
to do just,
uh, black-box testing
of the
user interface.
One of the ways
that you can do--
to make this happen--
one of the good things
about Google App Engine
is that you can have
several versions running
at the same time,
and they will be totally
separate from each other.
So you can deploy
to a test version
that you will never
make the default version,
and then you can test
against that.
And you can also have
different staging environments,
and so on.
That's one of the good things
of having an--
having an environment
where you, um--
where you basically
can start up
new things
and spread them around.
So that's very good,
and that makes it possible
to test these things remotely,
even if you don't get the
same kind of instant feedback
that you want if you do
local unit testing.
So Ruby right now runs on--
on Google App Engine.
It's, uh--there are
some caveats,
but it runs,
and there are efforts on the way
to make it even easier
to use it.
Ioke is something totally
different from Ruby, actually.
The only thing it shares
in common
is that it's, uh,
it's an implementation
or, actually,
it's a programming language
that runs on top of, um,
that runs of top of the JVM.
It's an experiment.
It's dynamically
strongly typed,
prototype based
object orientation,
homoiconic language,
inspired by several
different languages.
Let's see--
um,
and that's basically it.
Ioke is
a pretty different language.
I'm gonna very, very quickly
show you what it looks like
so you get
a feeling for it.
Well,
let's see, here.
Sorry,
I'm just gonna...
Okay.
So as I mentioned,
Ioke--
it's really--
it's an interesting thing.
It's an experiment to see how
expressive a language can be.
And one of the ways that it's
working against other things
is the fact that
if you make something
more and more
expressive,
your language is
gonna get slower and slower.
So Ioke is
a pretty slow language
compared to
any other language.
But it's--
it's pretty nice, so.
Basically, the main difference
between other languages
is that Ioke uses spaces
for calling, uh, methods,
so the above would have been
the equivalent
of doing
hello.println, instead.
The dot in Ioke is actually
the statement separator,
so, uh, the equivalent
of semicolons.
You can do most of the things
you can do in other languages:
1 + 2.
You can create a new method
called foo,
that takes an element
called x,
and then return
x*x, for example.
And I can call that
by doing...
something like that.
I have, um,
decimal numbers
and fractions.
Fractions that
are exact.
I don't have floats
because if--
if you want to use stuff
that needs floating numbers
you just--you should use
a faster language, anyway,
uh, basically.
[laughs]
It's, uh--
having floats in the language
is one of those things
that really,
really bugs me
because most programs
use them the wrong way.
I just decided
to take them away.
Okay, so I haven't really
shown you much of the language,
but the main thing
to remember is
it's a very
uniform language.
It allows you to work
with the Ast,
so you can actually
change the running code
while it's running,
so you have macros
of different kinds
syntactic macros,
and so on.
This gives language--
makes the language very, uh,
interesting to understand,
in some cases,
but it also makes it
very, very powerful.
Okay, so...
let's see.
IKanServe is something
very, very small.
It's basically
an Ioke equivalent of Rack.
It's a small, small, small
IokeServlet
that dispatches
to Ioke code.
You create a file called
iks, iks_application.ik,
and then you define
your actions there.
It looks very much
like Sinatra,
but it's not
as fully featured.
A typical example here--
uh, actually this is
an HTML Builder
that just allows you
to output HTML
by writing Ioke code.
I'm gonna
be using that too.
Okay, so Ioke runs
on top of Google App Engine,
uh, with the
IKanServe stuff.
Basically, it looks--
let's see if it's still up.
You never know.
Okay, here we go.
So Ioke from
the appspot.com
basically has
three different actions.
If you go somewhere
it doesn't know about,
it will just say
really nothing here.
If you go to foo,
it will say...
yeah, exactly,
that's what it says.
[laughs]
Sorry about that.
Let's just skip that
and look at the code
for--for the actions instead.
[laughs]
Of course, of course...
So basically, the--
the only thing I need here
is the
IKS application thingy.
And here
is an actionForPath,
and then I give
a regular expression
that starts with foo.
And then I say,
"hello world!!"
Actually, you know what
I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna do something that
I probably shouldn't do,
but let's try it.
I'm gonna try to deploy
this thing...again,
and see if that solves
the problem.
But I'm gonna do it
in the background.
Uh, uh, uh.
This should take
exactly two more seconds...
something like that.
Now we can see a full,
live deployed of--
that should be
very exciting for you.
Anyway, so basically what
you give to actionForPath
are just methods,
stuff that you can execute.
Ioke is very--
it's expression-based,
so everything
returns a value.
And when you call
the method "method,"
you get a new
method object
that you can work with,
right?
And in this case,
actionForPath foo
will just return--
basically,
what this code returns
is what is gonna be
rendered.
So this one will return
"hello world!!"
This one will return
"you requested this,"
and then take
the request pathInfo.
And, finally, this one
will create an HTML interface
with title("nada!")
and then, uh, in bold,
"...really nothing here..."
and you saw that earlier.
Uh, sorry about that.
I need to switch JDK.
I was very close
to showing you my--
my password for everyone.
If you're using Java 1.5
to deploy stuff,
you can't really
hide the password.
That would have been
perfect.
Okay, so I think this--
I've done many bad things while
doing live demonstrations,
but I think that that would
really have taken the prize.
Okay, so let's see if this one
comes up now.
Ah, "Hello world!!"
Okay, uh--
And here this one
is the one that actually
generates the HTML.
So you can see that
there is a connection
between what happens here and
what I have running over here.
It's nothing fancy.
It was
more of a proof concept
that you can actually
take another language
that doesn't have
a mature infrastructure
and you can just, uh,
deploy it,
and it works.
Okay, so, uh,
that's--that was supposed to be
very close to the end.
I didn't have
any more demonstrations,
but then
as it happens, uh,
a friend of mine at Google,
uh, [indistinct],
uh, managed to get me
an account at Google Wave
earlier today.
So I decided to create
something with that.
Let's see
if this one works.
Okay, so here we have
my Wave account.
Let's see if
I can resize it, so...
okay, so.
Down here I have something
called Iokebot@appspot.com.
That is a robot.
In the keynote,
you saw that they were talking
about robots for Wave.
A robot is basically just
something that can, um,
that can go in and participate
in the conversation with you.
So in this case, I can create
a new Wave to the Iokebot.
Can say, "Hello."
And what--this takes a
little time before it gets back.
[hums]
Ah!
And here we get--
let's see if I can resize this
so I can
get it larger.
"Hi from Ioke."
So this one
is actually live.
It's running on
appspot right now,
and it's running Ioke code that
can interact with Google Wave.
I'm almost certain
this is the first--
first third-party robot
anyone has created for Google--
for Google Wave,
because I spent some
very interesting hours earlier
trying to get
this working.
It's actually very, very
simple to do it, though.
There are a few
things you need.
Basically, uh,
you need a directory url file,
uh, underscore wave
that includes
capabilities.xml.
This one says that
we only, oops--
We only want to know
when participants change.
That's the only one
we're interested in.
And the profile name
should be IokeBot.
Then the code itself--
actually let's go into--
appengine-web
looks like this.
And IokeBot is
org.thoughtworks.iokebot.
IokebotServlet.
And I basically just map that
to this specific url,
which is the url
where--where, um,
Google Wave
will look for robots.
And you can actually see that
if you go to this url
on, um,
let's see, where...
IokeBot.
And we can go
to that url,
and you can see that,
in this case,
we're gonna get an--
this network is really terrible.
You will get "inappropriate"
because it always expects posts,
and I don't really know
the binary format for it anyway.
But, anyway,
so this IokeBot
is extremely simple.
What it does...is that it just
gets an Ioke application,
evaluates, uh,
it loads Ioke code,
and then sets, injects
the robot message bundle,
and then calls dispatch.
So if we look
at the IokeBot code,
can see
what's happening here.
Dispatch is basically
a method--
first logs
to the servletContext.
It logs
"dispatched."
And then we check if events
wasParticipantAddedToWave,
and then our name.
This basically just
checks that, okay--
the only time
we want to do something
is when--when this robot
is added to our conversation.
Then we get the wavelet,
append a new Blip,
and get a textView
for that blip,
and finally we say,
"Hi from Ioke."
And that was
exactly what happened here.
So that's actually
the whole story.
It's very simple
to do this,
and I was very happy
when I managed
to get that working,
actually.
I'm one of those persons
that likes shiny things.
Another thing
about shiny things,
I'm not sure if you noticed,
but the, the Google Wave team
seems to be, uh, have
a good, healthy knowledge
of the Firefly series.
Uh, you can see it
all over their documentation
and in their
error messages.
It's really cool,
actually.
I'm a fan of Firefly,
myself.
Okay, so--alternative languages
on the Google App Engine.
I think that the important thing
about Google App Engine
and the Java support
for it
is not the Java language
because, uh, the Java language
doesn't really give you
as many possibilities as you can
do in all these other languages.
You get automatic scaling,
of course,
but they get
harder to test.
Some of the languages
work pretty bad
because of the
security restrictions.
Reflection and threads
are the main ones,
file system too,
but they still work
pretty good anyway.
We've done experiments
with several languages
including Closure and Scala
and also
the regular Java stuff.
And they are all viable ways
of getting stuff uh, out,
very, very quickly.
It's really well suited
for it.
And it's funny,
the Ruby web frameworks--
there are several people,
actually,
deploying and thinking
about deploying
Rail applications, uh,
in production,
uh, on top of
Google App Engine,
which is pretty nice.
It's also interesting
to note
that the JDO and JPA--
uh, things that
Google has put on top
of DataStore--
actually doesn't really
mesh that well
with the way
big_table works.
And that's
one of the reasons
that I didn't
use the DataMapper APIs
for these, um--
for these examples
because I feel that
a lower level,
closer to big_table way
of working with the data
is actually
much better,
because a dynamic language
like Ruby
allows you to work
with dynamic new keys,
and that's exactly what
big_table allows you to do.
So I find that the mesh
of a dynamic language
with big_table
is actually much better than
the--the--
the Java versions.
So since you can use
any language,
that--there are about 200
different languages
for the JVM.
You can use most of them,
as far as I know,
on
Google App Engine.
Google App Engine allows you
to do polyglot programming,
where you have several different
things implemented
in different
languages.
And I think that's
really, really nice.
And it also allows you to think
in a more service-oriented way.
I definitely don't recommend
people to put all their stuff
in one application
on Google App Engine.
I mean, decide
what things you want to scale
in the way Google App Engine
allows you to scale,
and put that
in Google App Engine.
And then maybe you can
put other things
on Easy Tour,
whatever,
or in your own
local system,
and then combine them
to get the, uh--the uh--
a more interesting
result.
It's very easy
to get started.
And it's really a very p--
very powerful platform,
and, uh, it's been fun
playing around with it.
And as far as I know,
everyone is free
to get an account now.
So it's just
go ahead and play with it
and create something
really interesting.
And now I think
I can take questions.
Are there any questions?
Yes.
There are, sorry,
there are microphones
in the aisles--
uh, uh, aisles.
I can--
I can repeat your question
if you really don't feel like,
uh, like going there,
but, uh, we need
to get it recorded.
So...yes.
man: What should we
be using Ioke for
today in our application
development?
Bini: You should use it
for fun.
[laughter]
It's not
production ready.
It's an experiment.
It's, um, I aim for it
to be able to do
real production stuff,
uh, sometime
in the future,
but right now,
what it's really good at
is--is real expressibility.
When you need to do
internal DSLs
and stuff like that,
for example,
it's pretty good at.
But it's more of, um--
right now it's more of the...
proof of concept stage
where I hope
that other language designers
might use
some of the features
that I have designed
into Ioke.
Yes?
man: In summary,
you can use Ruby on Rails
with JRuby, right?
So in summary,
what are the pieces,
all the pieces I need
to use Ruby
with Ruby on Rails?
I'm a little unclear on that.
Bini: What are the pieces
you need to use Ruby on Rails?
man: Yeah, are there
any other pieces?
Bini: Well, on Google App Engine
or in general?
man: Um, I create
a Ruby on Rails application
on my hard drive.
Bingo, that's where it's at
using JRuby.
Okay, at that point
what do I have to do
to make it all
run in the cloud?
Bini: Well, basically
you need to download the STK
from Google App Engine.
And you can--
And you also need Warble.
And I think that's
the only things that--
those are the only things
that you really need.
man: Okay, and I've got
about 200 megabytes
to play with
in terms of file size.
Is that it?
Bini: Sorry, 200 megabytes?
man: You say
that Rails, of course,
takes up about 800 files,
right?
So I've got about 200
to play with?
Bini: There are ways
around that.
You can--your--
the gem files.
So you won't get up to those
high numbers immediately.
And you'll also get better speed
if you JAR them up.
So that's definitely
the recommended way.
You basically
just package the gems--
the Rails files
into JAR files,
and then they won't take up
as many numbers.
man: Okay.
Bini: Yes?
man: If JRuby
is really a, you know,
more powerful and quicker
implementation of Ruby,
why in general--
not necessarily
in the scope
of Google App Engine--
why would you not ever deploy
an application on JRuby--
a Rails application
on JRuby?
Bini: Why you would not
deploy a Rails application
on JRuby?
I have no good answer
to that one.
In general--
No, actually--
That sounds very glib,
but the thing is
that JRuby is really the best
deployment platform for Rails.
Period.
What does Rich say?
Rich has--
Rich has one of
the longest-running
JRuby on Rails
applications around.
[Rich speaking indistinctly]
Okay, so for the record--
So what Rich is saying,
one of the main reasons
is that there are some gems
that don't exist for JRuby,
specifically those gems that
depend on native extensions
need to be ported
in some way
to use equivalent
Java features.
man: I'm also
gonna answer this one.
It is the best deployment
platform, but if Google--
Like, for instance a lot
of the very goofy ways
of doing things you have
to kind of change the way...
[continues indistinctly]
So no more globals.
No more globals.
Ruby people love globals.
Don't do it.
[continues indistinctly]
Bini: Yes?
man: So you had mentioned
that running C extensions
isn't currently possible.
And Charles Nutter
in his Rails comp talk
talked about ways
that you might be able
to eventually deal with that.
But I like to look at that
as an opportunity
to rewrite those extensions
in Java.
And I was hoping that
certain things
that I've run into
in the past,
for example running Mechanize
and then Hpricot comes
and it starts parsing it
and it does a seg fault,
and I can't catch it,
I can't log it,
I have no idea what happened,
and my server dies.
I'm hoping I can
catch those exceptions
and do more logging.
And isn't creating
Java extensions actually
a solution to the problem?
Bini:
You are absolutely right,
except that--
It's a question of scale.
Most people that create
C extensions nowadays
actually have started
to provide Java equivalents
for JRuby too.
But the problem
is all those, like,
I don't know, we're talking
probably thousands
of C extensions
that existed before JRuby.
And no one is really
in their right mind
trying to port
all of them to Java.
But for the ones
that are used,
we try to port them.
I mean, Hpricot
is a good example
of a place where
we have ported it
to use the, um...
use Java instead.
Yes?
man: Does Rake test work on
the local development server?
Bini: Sorry?
man: Does Rake test command
work on the local--
Bini:
See, that's a good question.
I've heard that it works.
I never got it working.
I basically never got JRuby
running Rails locally
working very well.
man: And you were
talking about
running the actual test
on the App Engine proper.
How do you go around
the lack of production test
and development datastore?
So you'll be--
While you're running your test,
you'll be basically using
the datastore
that's in Google,
which would be the same
as production.
Bini:
There is not one datastore.
The datastore is versioned
exactly like
all the other stuff.
So if you deploy to one
version of App Engine,
you will actually
get a specific--
I mean, all the keys
and all the stuff
you can reach,
from that instance,
will only be those
that you can reach
from the same version.
So if you deploy to test,
you'll only have--
Basically it's like having
totally separate datastores.
No more questions?
Okay.
Thanks for your attention.
[applause]